il est à peine plus gros qu'un
réfrigérateur mettait se télescopent
tout neuf que les nazis mais en orbite
autour de la terre va accomplir des
miracles pour les spécialistes des
exoplanètes
l'appareil prend le relais de kepler
dont la durée de vie se termine et qu'il
ne scrute est qu'une toute petite partie
du ciel à la recherche de monde
habitable teyssot gay au contraire avoir
sondé tout le ciel il va trouver des
systèmes planétaires très près de nous
qu'on pourrait étudier avec lui plus de
die notamment avec le futur télescope
spatial james webb
où est ce qu'on va carrément être
capable de sonder l'atmosphère de ce
type la nature le télescope est équipé
de quatre caméras de très haute
résolution
chacune d'elles va couvrir une tranche
de ciel de la taille d'une constellation
pendant 27 jours puis passer à une autre
tranche jusqu'à couvrir 85 % de l'espace
visible à partir de la terre pour
détecter une planète les instruments de
test pour mesurer la minuscule baisse de
luminosité qu'elle provoque lorsqu'elle
passe devant son étoile
cette méthode permet également d'évaluer
sa taille est de décrire son orbite et
on s'attend à ce que la mission trouve
plusieurs milliers de planètes de ça il
va en avoir environ un millier peut-être
quelques milliers plus petit que neptune
mais encore de grosses planètes et
quelques centaines qu'on appelle des
super terres et puis quelques douzaines
de la taille de la terre plus les
étoiles observées par tess seront
brillante et meilleure sera la qualité
des données qu'on obtiendra sur les
planètes et lorsqu on les traitera sur
leur possible atmosphère
le but ultime c'est de trouver des
planètes similaires à la nôtre qui
aurait une atmosphère propice ou qui
aurait des conditions propices au
développement de la vie une atmosphère
contiendrait des signatures d'une
activité biologique s va suivre durant
toutes ces missions une orbite
elliptique autour de la terre en
retransmettant ces informations à chaque
fois qu'elle s'en approchera au plus
près comme c'est le cas avec de
nombreuses missions de la nasa
les données sont ensuite partager avec
la communauté scientifique mondiale ici
normand grondin radio canada montréal